for some local students having the
essentials the backpacks the pens other
school supplies
it's just not a reality a generous
donation though is giving children at
one school in the far east part of the
valley what they need for free
hector mejia live this morning at
whitney elementary with the details on
that hector good morning to you
hey there john good morning and this
donation means that every single student
set to return to whitney elementary
school on march 1st
will get this free backpack this is one
of them check how cool this is
we have marvel comics we have captain
america the hulk
and uh what's what's this guy i forgot
his name what is it
iron man of course that's iron man so
this is just one of several backpacks
here
and joining us live we have the
principal here at whitney elementary we
have melissa rheem
i love your backpack with that emoji on
it
yes we have the backpacks are stocked
like i said
with a full toiletry set for the student
and since the students can't share their
supplies we have a
pencil pouch for each student with their
their
own stuff that they can use in the
classroom so we don't have to share
any germs you know back in the day when
i was back in school only the kids had
the pencil
the pencil boxes yes yes so it'll be
it'll be great for our students we can't
wait to have them back on campus
so dozens of students are returning to
in person
uh to the mix of hybrid learning here at
whitney what percentage is that
we have 54 percent of our students
returning we're very
proud of that percent well over the
district average and so
our community is is truly ready to come
back on campus
and on that note you were telling me
this is just one of other donations for
the students here happening here today
yes we also are giving away books from
spread the word nevada
and also we have food bags for all the
families from catholic charities
we have some action going on here we are
still you know putting some school
supplies in some of these backpacks
and you were just telling us how crucial
these donations are especially for
students here
whitney elementary being a title one
school yes
our population definitely needs some
love we are so proud of our
community donors like max pond and
station casinos that really
step up for our families we're just a
little more than a week away are you
ready
yes yes we are ready
our doors will be open red carpet's
going to be rolled out let's
let's bring them back red carpet
confetti and sparkles
yes yes all right well
so parents had to sign up ahead of time
to receive these backpacks but that's a
story
uh dozens of backpacks being handed out
for free to the students here returning
on march 1st
at whitney elementary school reporting
live hector mejia
8 news now back to you guys are so
important to make that transition easy
for the kids especially out there in the
east part of the valley appreciate that
sir